This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. 99PI's Kurt Kohlstedt is our digital director, the co-author of the 99% Invisible city, and just generally someone who thinks and writes a lot about design. So naturally, assistive design, which is tailored for people with disabilities, has been on his radar. But Kurt's personal relationship with it changed pretty drastically about a year ago, when something happened to transform the way he moves through the world.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。99PI 的柯特·科尔斯特(Kurt Kohlstedt)是我们的数字总监，同时也是《99% Invisible 城市》一书的合著者，总体而言，他是一个经常思考和撰写设计相关内容的人。所以自然而然地，为残障人士量身定制的无障碍设计一直都在他的关注范围内。但大约在一年前，当发生了一件改变他体验世界方式的事情时，柯特与无障碍设计之间的个人关系发生了非常剧烈的变化。
Kurt recently wrote a series of articles on our website called Adapt or Design about his journey into the world of assistive technology. He's here to talk about the inspiration for that series and about designing his own assistive tech, some of which he now uses every day. Hey Kurt, thanks for talking to us about this. Hey Roman, yeah, good to be here. So this all started about a year ago when you sustained a pretty serious injury.
柯特最近在我们的网站上写了一系列名为《适应或设计》（Adapt or Design）的文章，讲述了他进入无障碍技术世界的历程。他今天来到这里，和我们聊聊该系列文章的灵感来源，以及他自己设计的一些无障碍技术，其中有些他现在每天都在用。嗨，柯特，谢谢你跟我们聊聊这个。嗨，罗曼，很高兴来到这里。这一切都始于大约一年前，当时你受了一次相当严重的伤。
Can you tell folks what happened? Yeah, well, I went to bed one night with my partner and the next thing I knew, I was wandering around my condo in sort of a daze and I'm not sure how I got home from her place. Like I don't remember like an entirely normal day that I spent with her before that. I just kind of like ended up in this walking dream state and I was a bit
你能跟听众讲讲当时发生了什么吗？好吧，有一天晚上我和伴侣上床睡觉，等我再恢复意识时，我正处于一种恍惚状态，在我的公寓里转悠，而且我甚至不确定自己是怎么从她那儿回家的。就像我完全不记得之前和她一起度过的那个极其平常的日子。我只是不知怎么地陷入了这种梦游般的状态，而且我有点
concerned because my, my right arm was paralyzed and I couldn't feel anything in that arm. And so I called my girlfriend at work and she was like, you know, are you okay? And I said, I'm not really sure. And I think that's like a universal signal of like, okay, you're not okay. Because if you don't know how to answer that question, that's a bad sign. And so she immediately came over to my place from work and was like, we should go to the emergency room as soon as she saw me. And I was like, well, I don't know, maybe we should get a second opinion.
担心，因为我的右手臂瘫痪了，而且那条胳膊没有任何知觉。于是我给正在上班的女朋友打电话，她就问，你知道，你还好吗？我说，我不太确定。我想这就像是一个通用的信号，意思是，好吧，你确实不好。因为如果你不知道该怎么回答这个问题，那就是个不妙的征兆。所以她立刻从公司赶到我的住处，一看到我就说，我们得去急诊室。而我说，嗯，我不知道，也许我们应该听听第二意见。
How about we call my dad first? Who is not a medical doctor. No, he's got a PhD, So he's a he's a doctor You know a doctor of geophysics. So he's like a rock doctor So yeah, I wasn't exactly thinking straight Yeah, you know that was very clear and so my girlfriend talked over me as I like tried to explain things and she's just like come Here now we need to go to the hospital Yeah, and so he did he came picked us up and and drove us to the hospital. Yeah. And so he did. He came, picked us up, and drove us to the hospital. So you went to the hospital.
不如我们先给我爸打个电话？他可不是个医生。不，他有博士学位，所以他是个医生，你知道的，地球物理学博士。所以他就像是个岩石医生。所以，是的，我当时脑子确实不太清醒。是的，你知道，这太明显了。于是我女朋友打断了我，当时我还在试图解释，她直接说：现在就来，我们必须去医院。是的，所以他真的来了，来接我们并把我们开车送到了医院。是的，所以他真的来了。他来接我们，并开车送我们去了医院。所以你去了医院。
You're talking to some doctors. And they're helping you fill in some blanks of this injury. So could you describe what they think happened? Yeah. So there was a lot of mystery. There were a lot of tests. And I ended up staying in the hospital for a full week as they sort of unraveled this puzzle as best they could.
你和一些医生交谈，他们帮你填补了这次受伤的一些空白。所以你能描述一下他们认为发生了什么吗？是的。当时有很多谜团，做了很多检查。我最终在医院住了整整一周，因为他们尽最大努力解开这个谜题。
And what they concluded was that I'd had some sort of neurocardiac event and had wound up unconscious on the floor, lying on top of my arm, which cut off blood flow and ultimately did a ton of damage to my brachial plexus, which is this nerve nexus between your spinal column and your arm. And the nerves all the way down my arm to my fingertips were severely damaged. Yeah.
他们的结论是，我经历某种心脏神经事件，然后不省人事地倒在地板上，身体压在胳膊上，这切断了血液循环，最终对我的臂丛神经造成了极大的损害，臂丛神经就是连接你脊椎和手臂的神经网络。我整条手臂一直到指尖的神经都严重受损。是的。
And at this point, was there a notion as to how temporary or permanent, you know, your arm paralyzation was going to be? Yeah, it was sort of a slow, slow, slow unfolding because yeah, I did. I went from thinking, oh, you know, my arm's just like asleep, just like really, really deeply asleep maybe. But you know, nothing's broken and I'm at the hospital, things are gonna be fine.
在那个时候，对于你的手臂瘫痪会是暂时的还是永久的，你有什么概念吗？是的，这是一个非常、非常、非常缓慢的揭晓过程，因为是的，我确实经历了这个过程。我一开始以为，“哦，你知道，我的胳膊只是麻了，可能只是麻得非常、非常深而已。”但你知道，没有什么骨折，我在医院里，一切都会好起来的。
So like slowly understanding as they explained things that like, this is not an injury you recover from in days, weeks, months, sometimes even years. Like it is an injury that you may incrementally recover from up to a point, but it's permanent. And so I had to go from thinking of it in terms of being an injury to thinking of it
所以，随着他们的解释，我才慢慢明白，这不是那种能在几天、几周、几个月甚至几年内恢复的伤。这是一种你可能会在某种程度上逐渐恢复，但它是永久性的伤。所以我不得不改变对它的看法，不再把它当成一种单纯的受伤，而是把它
in terms of being a disability. Yeah, yeah. The reason why I wanna talk to you about this and have this be an episode of the show is that you have a mind that has written and thought about design for a very long time, like all your professional career, you've done it for us for almost 10 years at this point.
看作是一种残疾。是的，是的。我之所以想跟你谈论这件事，并让它成为节目的一期内容，是因为你的大脑长期以来一直在思考和撰写关于设计的内容——可以说贯穿了你的整个职业生涯，到目前为止你已经为我们写了将近 10 年了。
And this is a world that is designed for two functional arms. And now you put in this situation where all of a sudden the two handedness or the right handed dominant two handedness of the world becomes very, very clear. And so what I'm hoping is you can kind of walk us through the world you encountered when you left the hospital. Yeah, and what I'll say is while I was in the hospital in my kind of bubble, I mean,
而这是一个为两只功能健全的手臂所设计的世界。现在你被置于这样一种境地：突然之间，这个世界的双手机制，或者说以右手为主导的双手机制，变得非常非常明显。所以我希望你能带我们了解一下当你离开医院时所面对的世界。是的，我想说的是，当我在医院里处于那种类似泡沫的环境中时，我的意思是，
I was worried about, you know, things like writing about design, you know? This kind of big picture stuff, but you're right. I mean, as soon as you leave that kind of safe, enclosed, contained space, reality hits like a brick. And the first thing you notice is in swapping out your hospital robe for your pants and your shirt, suddenly I'm sitting there with my non-dominant left arm trying to put these things on and figure out like, okay, well now I've got my phone in my right pocket, I can't even reach that
我担心的都是诸如撰写关于设计的内容之类的事情，你知道吗？这些宏观层面的东西，但你是对的。我的意思是，一旦你离开那种安全、封闭、受保护的空间，现实就像砖头一样迎面砸来。你注意到的第一件事就是，当你把病号服换成裤子和衬衫时，突然间我坐在那里，用我那不占优势的左臂试图把这些衣服穿上，然后琢磨着：“好吧，现在我的手机在右口袋里，我甚至都够不到它了
anymore. It immediately becomes clear that there's a lot of adaptation that's going to need to take place. So what are some of the solutions that you found? Like how did you deal with, you know, your phone being in your right hand pocket and you can't quite reach it? So I don't have my right pocket sort of accessible anymore, which means I've got half the pocket capacity. And so what I did was I started pulling things out of that pocket and they cooking those things up in different places so for example, I took everything out of my wallet and I put it in one of those kind of Retractable key card reader things that you use for access to you know, the bus or the train or your work
。”很明显，有大量的适应过程将要发生。那么你找到了哪些解决方案呢？比如你是如何应对诸如手机在右口袋里却够不着之类的问题的？所以我的右口袋不再那么容易够到了，这意味着我的口袋容量减少了一半。所以我做的是，我开始把东西从那个口袋里拿出来，把它们挂在不同的地方。例如，我把钱包里的所有东西都拿出来，放进那种可伸缩的钥匙卡读取器里，就是那种你用来刷卡进公交车、地铁或公司的那种。
So that was good It got the wallet out of the way and I took my phone and I put it in this holster Which I could then clip, then clip on the side of my pants. Everything that I could, I moved somewhere else, keeping it sort of readily accessible, but out of the way at the same time. And one of the very few advantages of wearing a bunch of different slings early on was that I had a lot of places to clip things.
所以这挺好的，它把钱包腾出来了。然后我把手机放进这个枪套里，我可以把它夹在裤子侧面。所有我能转移的东西，我都转移到别的地方去了，既保持随时随地容易拿到，同时又不会碍事。在早期，戴着一堆不同的吊带带来的极少数好处之一，就是我有很多可以夹东西的地方。
One thing that comes to mind as something that is especially difficult to do with one hand is putting on shoes, especially shoes with laces that need to be tied. And it also seems like a weird mental state to be in because the last time you couldn't tie your shoes, you were probably a small child, you know? And so could you talk about how you've managed
我能想到的单手做起来特别困难的一件事就是穿鞋，特别是那些需要系鞋带的鞋子。而且这也感觉是一种很奇怪的心理状态，因为你上一次不会系鞋带的时候，大概还是个小孩子，对吧？所以你能谈谈你是如何应对
that particular challenge? Yeah, well at least for me all of my shoes are laced. So I went out and I looked for Something that would be a sort of prefab, you know off-the-shelf all in one solution and I found these lace locking kits and They have these widgets inside that you thread your laces through and then you sort of cinch the widget up and down. It's kind of like like cinching up a bolo tie. But then like you've got a problem because your laces are
这个特定挑战的吗？是的，至少对我来说，我所有的鞋子都是带鞋带的。所以我出去找了一种现成的、开箱即用的多合一解决方案，我找到了这些鞋带锁定套件。它们的内部有这些小部件，你可以把鞋带穿过去，然后把小部件上下拉紧。这有点像系波罗领带。但接着你就有了一个问题，因为你的鞋带
no longer being looped and tied. And so they need to be shortened. But once you clip your laces shorter, the ends immediately start to unravel. And so the other part of these kits are these tips that clip onto the end. And they're kind of like big and plastic and ugly and uncannily. And so I went out looking for some kind of more DIY, subtle solution that wouldn't be quite so loud. And so what I ended up doing is I bought heat shrink thermoplastic tubing, which basically like you slot
不再能打圈和系上了，所以它们需要剪短。但一旦你把鞋带剪短，末端就会立刻开始散开。所以这些套件的另一部分是夹在末端的金属头。它们看起来又大、又塑料、又丑，而且很不自然。所以我开始寻找某种更具 DIY 风格、更微妙、不那么显眼的解决方案。所以我最终做的是，我买了一根热缩热塑性管，基本上你可以把
the clipped end of your lace into this. And then, ideally I think you take like a heating element or something more official, but I just ran a lighter underneath it to sort of cinch it up. That's a heating element, yeah. Yeah, it's a heating element. And although I will say, one thing I learned from that is, you know, don't try this at home, especially
剪短的鞋带头插进去。然后，理想情况下我想你应该用加热元件或者更正式的东西，但我只是拿了一个打火机在它下面烤了一下，把它收紧。那是加热元件，对吧？是的，是个加热元件。虽然我得说，从中我学到的一点是，你知道，不要在家尝试这个，特别是
when you're one handed. Like I'm sitting there, you know, like toying around with a lighter, which is hot and burning my fingers. And it was like an early realization that like I have one working hand. I cannot afford to jack this thing up, right? Like it's, this is now more vital than ever.
当你只有一只手的时候。就像我坐在那里，你知道的，摆弄着打火机，这东西很烫，烫伤了我的手指。这让我很早就意识到，我只有一只好手，我可承担不起把这只手搞砸的后果，对吧？就像是，现在这只手比以往任何时候都更加至关重要。
But the result is you have these aglets that look like they come sort of straight out of the factory, right? And so that's the thing that, you know, signals to people, hey, I've got normal shoelaces on. Okay. So you've got lock laces, which are a great way to adapt the shoes that you already have
但结果是，你得到的鞋带头看起来就像是直接从工厂生产出来的一样，对吧？所以这就是向人们发出信号的东西，嘿，我穿着正常的鞋带。好吧。所以你有了锁紧鞋带（lock laces），这是一种改造你现有鞋子的好方法，
so that they're easier to put on one-handed. But you also looked into some accessible off-the-shelf options. And what you discovered there was that there were some really innovative, creative shoe designs out there. Yeah, so, lock laces are fast and cheap, and they're a great way to, you know, make use of your existing footwear. But I did end up getting a pair of specially designed, hands-free shoes that basically, like, you pop out of them and they break open in the middle.
这样单手穿起来更容易。但你也研究了一些现成的无障碍选项。你在那里发现的是，市面上有一些真正创新、有创意的鞋子设计。是的，所以，锁紧鞋带速度快又便宜，是利用你现有鞋履的好方法。但我最终确实买了一双专门设计的免提鞋，基本上，你可以一脚蹬出来，它们会在中间裂开。
Like, they kind of, they like wedge themselves open and you slide your foot out into the air. And then when you're ready to put them on, you slide your foot in, press your heel down and it just locks back into place. And what I love about them is partly, you know, how well they work and that they sort of hug your heel, but also there's this kind of rubber band
就像它们会自己撑开，然后你把脚滑到空气中。当你准备穿上时，把脚滑进去，脚后跟往下踩，它就会卡回原位。我最喜欢它们的地方，一部分在于它们的工作原理有多好，以及它们如何包裹你的脚后跟，但也有一种橡胶带
that runs along the side and that's what locks it into place in both configurations, both open and closed. And so being able to see that structural element really sort of tickles my design fancy. I love the kind of honesty and clarity of that design. And I think that was part of what drew me to that particular pair. It's like the Central Pompidou of know, like all the mechanics are on the outside
沿着侧面延伸，正是它在开启和关闭这两种状态下将其锁定在到位。能够看到这种结构元素，真的很大程度上满足了我的设计趣味。我喜欢那种设计中的诚实和清晰。我想这也是吸引我买这特定一双鞋的原因之一。它就像是蓬皮杜中心，你知道的，所有的机械结构都在外面，
to show you how the thing works. It's exactly that. It's very expressive in that way. And yet it also looks like a normal pair of shoes. So to the uninitiated, it doesn't look like you're wearing something janky, but if you know what you're looking at, you can see how it works. And that's what I love. So you found a new design in shoe that you really love. Talk to me about some of the things
向你展示这东西是如何运作的。完全就是这样。它在那种意义上非常有表现力。然而它看起来又像是一双普通的鞋。所以对于外行人来说，它看起来不像是你穿了什么劣质货，但如果你知道你在看什么，你就能看出它是如何运作的。这就是我所爱的。所以你找到了一种你非常喜欢的鞋子的新设计。跟我聊聊其中一些
that you've grown to hate as a person navigating the world with one arm. Yeah, so one of the things that became the bane of my existence are conventional plastic side sort of clippy buckles, the kinds that you find on backpacks and you know, everything else in your life that carries things. And so one of the problems that I discovered was that buckles are really hard to work with
作为单臂在世界上穿行的人，你逐渐开始痛恨的事情。是的，所以其中一件让我深恶痛绝的事情就是传统的塑料侧插式快拆插扣，那种你在背包里找到的，以及生活中用来承载东西的无障碍物品上随处可见的插扣。我发现的问题之一是，插扣真的很难操作，
and hard to like unclick and hard to snap back into place. And you know, those are everywhere. They're on your backpack, they're on all these different things. But what I found was when I was looking for this strap to keep one of my orthoses in place, which is the sling that kind of kept my limp arm from dangling and just sort of hanging there, I needed something that would basically serve like a sternum strap on a backpack. And what I found was one that has a magnetic buckle. And once I realized the incredible, amazingness of magnetic buckles, I just started putting them on everything. Like I took a bunch of my stuff to the tailor and like had them replace a bunch of things. I did some of my own and yeah. And so now everything that can have a
很难解开，也很难卡回原位。你知道，这些东西到处都是。它们在你的背包上，在所有这些不同的东西上。但我发现的是，当我在寻找这个带子来固定我的一个矫形器时——也就是那种防止我的无力手臂下垂并挂在那里的吊带——我需要某种基本上可以像背包胸带一样的东西。我找到的是一个带有磁吸插扣的带子。一旦我意识到磁吸插扣那不可思议的奇妙之处，我就开始把它用在所有东西上。我把一堆东西拿给裁缝，让他们把一堆东西都换成了磁吸的。我自己也做了一些，是的。所以现在所有能用磁吸插扣的东西，我都换成了磁吸插扣。磁吸插扣之所以如此神奇，是因为磁铁的力量会把它们拉到一起，你可以把它们卡到位，
magnetic buckle has a magnetic buckle And what makes a magnetic buckle so amazing is that the force of the magnet pulls it together and you can snap into place You can kind of do it all with one hand. You just have to get them close together Yeah, that's right. Part of it is like the beauty of being able to unclip it one-handed but really like the master stroke is that It just snaps back into place and the hold is strong. Like once you hear that click, it's like that thing isn't going anywhere. That's a really strong connection because it's like both a magnetic and a mechanical connection. Like
你几乎可以单手完成这一切。你只需要把它们靠近就行。是的，没错。部分原因在于能够单手解开它的美妙之处，但真正的大招是它能直接卡回原位，而且抓握力很强。一旦你听到那个咔哒声，就好像那东西绝对掉不下来了。这是一个非常牢固的连接，因为它既是磁力连接又是机械连接。
the magnet brings it into place and then once it snaps, it's like you need to mechanically unfasten it to get it free. That's awesome. I mean, it's safe to say that most of the world is harder to navigate, obviously, with one arm versus two. But also, through your injury, you've discovered that some of the world is accidentally, you know,
磁铁把它带到定位，一旦它卡上，就像你需要用机械方式解开它才能释放它一样。这太棒了。我的意思是，可以肯定地说，与两只胳膊相比，用一只胳膊在世界上穿行显然要艰难得多。但同时，通过你的受伤，你也发现这个世界在某种程度上无意中
kind of works for a left-handed person or one working left arm person. Yeah, I've become sort of fond of saying that the world is designed for two handed people first, right handed people second, and left handed people last. And in most cases, that's the case. But weirdly, like when I was kind of gearing back up to like trying to drive again,
对左撇子或者只有一只健康的左臂的人很友好。是的，我开始喜欢说这样一句话：这个世界首先是为双手健全的人设计的，其次是为右撇子设计的，最后才是为左撇子设计的。在大多数情况下确实如此。但奇怪的是，当我准备重新开始开车时，
which was, you know, scary, a scary thought. And like I was gonna, you know, go off into a side road, you know, like roll around a parking lot, try to figure it out. And as soon as I got behind the wheel and sort of got myself into position and started, I realized like, oh, this is actually surprisingly easy because I grew up using a stick shift.
这（说实话）是一个可怕的想法。我想我会去一条小路上，你知道的，在停车场里兜圈子，试着摸索。但当我一坐到方向盘后面，摆好姿势并启动时，我意识到，哦，这其实出奇地容易，因为我从小习惯开手动挡。
But these days, your right hand doesn't have a lot to do. It's like the kind of tertiary functions of like windshield wipers and things, Sure, but that's about it. The left hand is what controls things like the blinkers and like, you know, the headlights and all of that stuff. So driving around left handed is actually not that bad. Yeah, which which I was not really expecting. But it's one of those things you only discover through trying, right? Yeah,
但如今，你的右手臂其实没有太多事可做。它只负责雨刮器之类的第三级功能，当然，仅此而已。左手才负责控制转向灯和前大灯之类所有这些东西。所以单手左撇子开车其实没那么糟糕。是的，这其实是我没料到的。但这就是那种只有通过尝试才能发现的事情，对吧？是的，
yeah. It's so surprising to me, but it's one of those things you only discover through trying, right? Yeah, it's so surprising to me because it's totally true, but we created so much of the design of the car based on the fact that changing gears is difficult and is better used for your right hand, mostly. And you're doing it constantly. That's where the control comes from, right? That gear shifting up and down, it's this regular thing. And then when it's gone, it leaves this control comes from, right? It's like that gear shifting up and down, it's this regular thing. And then when it's gone,
是的。这让我感到非常惊讶，但这就是那种只有通过尝试才能发现的事情，对吧？是的，这让我感到非常惊讶，完全是事实，但我们创造了汽车的大部分设计，都是基于这样一个事实：换挡很困难，主要还是留给你的右手臂来做比较好。而且你需要不断地换挡。控制力就是这么来的，对吧？向上和向下换挡，这是一个常规动作。当它消失时，
it leaves this void of opportunity, right? Yeah, so it's so funny to me that cars might be one of those things that is just sort of accidentally designed for left-handed people, at least in the US and all right. Yeah, yeah, yeah, lots of caveats. But yes, like it is absolutely the case that like when I am driving, it's like one of the few, if not the only time when I'm like, oh's one of the few, if not the only time,
它留下了一个机会的真空，对吧？是的，所以这对我来说太滑稽了，汽车可能是那种无意中为左撇子设计的东西，至少在美国是这样。当然，有很多前提条件。但是是的，绝对是这样的，当我开车时，这是为数不多的、甚至可能是仅有的几个时刻之一，我会想：
when I'm like, okay, thank goodness that it is my right hand that doesn't work and not my left. That is not normally the case. After the break, Kurt talks about the surprisingly difficult task of finding the perfect one-handed keyboard. I'm back with 99PI's Kurt Kohlstedt.
“哦，这是为数不多的、甚至可能是仅有的几个时刻之一，我会想，好吧，谢天谢地，是我右手不能用，而不是左手。”通常情况下可不是这样的。休息过后，柯特将谈论寻找完美单键盘这一出人意料的困难任务。我同 99PI 的柯特·科尔斯特一起回到了节目中。
Kurt, we've talked about some of the ways you've designed around various challenges following your injury, but we haven't yet talked about one of your most personal obstacles, which is the ability to write. So you are a design journalist. It is your job to write. I know that is your great joy to write, but typing one-handed is incredibly arduous, probably more so than most people realize. Yeah, the thing that I realized very quickly, and I kind of knew even before I tried it was that the process of writing isn't just, you know, typing out keys and like, you know, hitting letters that make words and things.
柯特，我们已经讨论了你受伤后围绕各种挑战进行设计的一些方式，但我们还没有谈到你最个人的障碍之一，也就是书写的能力。你是一名设计记者，书写是你的工作。我知道写作是你的巨大快乐，但单手打字极其艰辛，可能比大多数人意识到的还要艰难。是的，我很快意识到的事情，其实在我尝试之前就隐约知道，写作的过程不仅仅是敲击键盘和打出组成单词的字母之类的事情。
It's like constantly re-editing yourself and like doing all of this on the fly and at speed and jumping between the mouse and the keyboard. So, yeah, it's safe to say that that was like in many ways my biggest concern. Big picture. So I want to talk about speech to text because speech to text has gotten quite advanced in the last few years and I've seen you use it on Slack. But you've said that this is not something that works for you as a writer in a more general sense.
它是一个不断自我重新编辑的过程，而且所有这一切都要在飞行中、在高速下完成，还需要在鼠标和键盘之间来回切换。所以，是的，可以肯定地说，在许多方面，这是我最大的担忧。从宏观角度来看。所以我现在想谈谈语音转文字，因为语音转文字在过去几年里已经变得相当先进了，我看到你在 Slack 上用过它。但你说过，作为一名作家，这种方法在更广泛的意义上并不适合你。
Can you talk about that? Well, the reality is I do use it like it's part of my sort of kit of tools for writing and other things. Like it's great for texting. It's great for emails. But if you didn't know this already about me, I'm a bit of a rambler. So when it comes to writing and like my particular process, like I spend a lot of time going over things and refining and editing on the fly. And so for for me personally, it leads me down this dangerous path of just being verbose, which I am verbose enough in my everyday life. But one of the things I've learned is that different things work for different people,
你能谈谈这个吗？好吧，现实情况是我确实在使用它，它是我用于写作和其他事情的工具包的一部分。它非常适合发短信，也适合发电子邮件。但如果你还不知道关于我的这一点，我其实有点爱唠叨。所以在写作以及我特有的创作过程中，我会花大量时间去审视、润色和即时编辑。所以对我个人而言，这会把我引向一条危险的道路，那就是变得冗长，而我在日常生活中已经够冗长的了。不过我学到的一点是，不同的方法适用于不同的人，
and it all kind of works together in the end. Yeah. So companies do make keyboards specifically designed for one hand. I know that you got kind of obsessed with trying these out. Can you describe some of your process of learning about one handed keyboards? Yeah. Yeah. Well, even before I kind of got to those, I really, you know, I looked for ways to do it on a normal keyboard, right? Like right one handed. And what I discovered is there are touch typing systems for doing that, but you move your hand so much, it really subjects you to extra stress.
到头来它们都是相辅相成的。是的。所以确实有公司专门为单手设计键盘。我知道你当时对尝试这些键盘有点着迷。你能描述一下你了解单手键盘的一些过程吗？是的。好吧，甚至在接触到那些之前，我真的（你知道的）寻找过在普通键盘上单手打字的方法。
And so like it really quickly became apparent that if I was going to stay a writer, I needed like a one handed hardware solution that was really designed for this to minimize hand movement. So I did a bunch of research as one does. Well, as you do. I don't know as one does, necessarily. But go ahead, continue.
我发现有针对这种需求的触打系统，但你的手需要移动太多，这确实会给你带来额外的压力。所以它很快就变得很明显：如果我想继续当作家，我需要一个真正为此设计的单手硬件解决方案，以尽量减少手的移动。所以我做了一番研究，正如人们所做的那样。
Yeah, yeah, I dove very, very, very deep into this. And I kind of looked at everything in existence. So what are some of the highlights of the things that you found? Well, I basically narrowed it down to like three choices. And they all were surprisingly different like it's not like a two-handed keyboard where like everything is kind of the same just like with tweaks and mods like we're talking totally different layouts and interfaces
嗯，正如你所做的那样。我不一定“正如人们所做的那样”。不过请继续，往下说。是的，是的，我非常、非常、非常深入地研究了这一点。我基本上把现存的所有东西都看了一遍。那你发现的亮点有哪些呢？好吧，我基本上把它缩小到三个选择。而且它们出奇地不同——它不像双手键盘那样，所有的东西都差不多，只是做了一些微调和修改——我们说的是完全不同的布局和界面。
and so before I could really decide like I'm gonna get one of these especially because they're really expensive yeah I was like I have to try them and they also you know they're not sitting out at Best Buy, you have to get them somehow. So the first step for me was finding this this great adaptive tech library here in Minnesota, which loans these things out for free, like a normal library, except a normal library that lends out things that are worth like 1000 thousands of dollars. So yeah, they sent me these keyboards that I requested and I started using them and seeing how they worked.
所以在真正决定我要买其中一个之前，特别是考虑到它们真的很贵，是的，我就想：我必须先试试它们。而且它们也不太可能摆在百思买（Best Buy）的货架上，你必须通过某种方式弄到它们。所以对找到这里明尼苏达州这个出色的无障碍技术图书馆来说，我的第一步就是它们像普通图书馆一样免费借出这些东西，除了普通图书馆不会借出价值几千美元的东西。所以是的，他们把我要求的这些键盘寄给了我，我开始使用它们并观察它们的运作方式。
That's an incredible service. I mean, every few days I am like wowed by the importance and the sort of great innovation of libraries. And that's just that's just stunning. Okay, so they sent you a few keyboards to try, some very expensive keyboards that you'd have to special order. What did you find?
这真是一个不可思议的服务。我的意思是，每隔几天我都会对图书馆的重要性以及那种伟大的创新惊叹不已，这简直太令人震撼了。好吧，他们给你寄了几个键盘来试用，都是一些你需要特制的非常昂贵的键盘。你发现了什么？
Well, so I started with this one that's sort of like the Buick of one-handed keyboards. It's like this vintage, giant 1970s clunker and it's called the Meltron. And it's made by this company that sort of really made a splash in ergonomic design early on, like when that wasn't really a thing, by curving their keyboards.
好吧，我从这个开始，它有点像单手键盘中的别克汽车。这是一个复古的、巨大的 1970 年代老古董，名字叫作 Meltron。它是由一家在早期（当人体工学设计还不是那么回事的时候）通过把键盘做成弧形而在人体工学设计领域引起轰动的公司制造的。
And they started with a two-handed design and quickly moved to this really kind of sculptural, very provocative looking one-handed design. You showed me the Maltron. The Maltron is curved in this way that it has this concave bowl of key. So you sort of set your hand inside of the bowl. And from that vantage point,
它们从双手设计开始，迅速转向了这种非常具有雕塑感、看起来极具挑衅性的单手设计。你给我看过 Meltron。Meltron 的弧度很特别，它有一个凹陷的碗状按键区。所以你可以把手放在这个碗状区域里。从那个有利位置，
you can sort of reach more keys with your hand in one position. Exactly, exactly. Because like on a flat surface, right, you have to sort of move your hand about, but it's like, if you were just hovering your hand and you can flick your fingers in three dimensions, like having that bowl shape is really awesome
你只需把手放在一个位置，就可以够到更多的按键。完全正确，完全正确。因为在平坦的表面上，你知道的，你不得不把手移来移去，但如果你只是把手悬空，并且可以在三维空间里弹动你的手指，拥有那种碗状的形状真的很棒，
and it makes things a lot more accessible. But I think what really kind of killed it for me was that only about half the keys are even in that bowl. Like the alphabet is there and some of like the basic, you know, modifier keys like shift and control are there. But there are a bunch of keys, about half, that are on these flat surfaces outside the bowl. So while your hand is in there,
它让事情变得更容易触及。但我认为真正让我对它失去兴趣的是，只有大约一半的按键甚至都不在那个碗里。字母在那里，一些基本的修改键（比如 Shift 和 Control）也在那里。但还有一堆按键，大约有一半，都在碗外面的平坦表面上。所以当你的手在里面时，
it can reach all the keys very easily, but once you lift it out, you have to move it around a lot. And I'm not sure, in the end, if I ended up moving my hand less or more while using this. Then a conventional keyboard. Yeah, exactly. Okay, so the Maltron didn't work for you. Another one that you have mentioned to me is called the tippy
它可以非常容易地够到所有按键，但一旦你拿出来，你就得大幅度移动它。最后我也不确定，在使用这个键盘时，我的手到底是移动得变少了还是变多了。比起传统键盘。是的，完全如此。好吧，所以 Meltron 对你并不适用。你向我提到的另一个键盘叫作 Tippy
That's shaped like a slice of pie. What lessons about one-hand typing did you learn about the tippy? Yeah, well like that shape is is really nice It's like if you splay out your fingers and like trace like a shape around that sort of flat palm of yours That's kind of the shape of this board. And that means you can essentially reach everything without anything but like a little bit of wrist movement, which is great, like minimal movement, awesome. And like one of the clever tricks that they employed was sort of pushing certain keys off to the periphery that were less important and making the core keys
它的形状像一片披萨。关于单手打字，你从 Tippy 学到了哪些经验？是的，这种形状真的很不错。就像如果你把手指张开，沿着你那平坦的手掌周围描绘一个形状，那差不多就是这个键盘的形状。这意味着你基本上可以在不需要太多手腕移动的情况下够到所有东西，这太棒了——移动最少，太棒了。而且它们采用的聪明技巧之一是，把一些不太重要的小键推到外围，而把那些
that are like right under your hand serve more functions. So like letters, instead of just being like a letter key that generates either a small or a cap version of a letter, it might also generate a number. And so if you press down a key, you can access this additional layer of functions in that most accessible part of the board. Yeah, so you're moving your hand less,
就在你手底下的核心键赋予更多功能。所以像字母一样，它不再仅仅是一个生成字母的小写或大写版本的字母键，它可能还会生成一个数字。所以如果你按下某个键，你就可以访问键盘中最容易够到的部分的这层额外功能。是的，所以你移动手变少了，
but keys take on more functions by using like alt keys and shift keys and stuff people are familiar with. Yeah. This also required a steep learning curve and so you decided this was not for you. Yeah, honestly, learning a whole new keyboard layout and a whole new set of specialized keys using only my non-dominant hand,
但按键通过使用诸如 Alt 键和 Shift 键以及人们熟悉的东西，承担了更多功能。是的。这同样需要一个陡峭的学习曲线，所以你决定这不适合你。是的，老实说，仅仅用我那只不占优势的手去学习一个全新的键盘布局和一整套全新的专用按键，
it really got to be a bit overwhelming, to be honest. I can imagine that. And of course, that doesn't mean that this is a bad design. I suspect Tippy could work great for somebody who is young and starting from scratch. Somebody who's not burdened by both having to unlearn one system and then learn another system at the same time.
说实话，这真的变得有点让人难以招架了。我可以想象。当然，这并不意味着这是一个糟糕的设计。我猜 Tippy 对于一个年轻的、从零开始的人来说会非常管用。一个不用同时背负着“先忘掉一个系统，然后再学习另一个系统”双重负担的人。
Yeah, which leads us to one of the designs for one-handed keyboards that you liked the best, which is the half-quarty. Could you describe what a half-quarty keyboard is? Well, as the name suggests, it is kind of like half of a quarty keyboard, almost as if you just cut one in half and kept the left side only. Right, so I'm looking at a picture of it now,
是的，这就把我们引向了你最喜欢的单手键盘设计之一，也就是半 QWERTY 键盘（half-quarty）。你能描述一下什么是半 QWERTY 键盘吗？嗯，顾名思义，它有点像 QWERTY 键盘的一半，几乎就像你把它从中间切开，只保留左边一样。对的，我现在正在看它的图片，
and it's really small, like maybe half or even a third the size of a standard QWERTY keyboard. And like you said, the main keys on this thing are the ones that you'd find on the left side of a standard keyboard, minus the numbers and some of the modifier keys. Right, right, exactly. And so the design is made to tap into our muscle memory,
它真的很小，大概只有标准 QWERTY 键盘的一半甚至三分之一大小。就像你说的，这东西上面的主要键就是你在标准键盘左边能找到的那些键，去掉了数字和一些修改键。对，完全正确。所以这个设计旨在利用我们的肌肉记忆，
our ability to sort of brain-body connect with different parts of the keyboard as we touch type. And it's a little hard to picture at first, but just imagine drawing a line down the center of a normal two-handed keyboard, and then folding that keyboard in half from right to left along that line. It's like closing a book.
利用我们在盲打时大脑与身体连接键盘不同部分的能力。一开始可能有点难以想象，但只要想象在正常的双手键盘正中央画一条线，然后沿着这条线把那个键盘从右向左对折。就像合上一本书一样。
And so now every letter on the right matches up with a letter on the left and is layered on top of that letter. And then to access that next layer, you have to press a modifier key. So for example, the Q key is in the far upper left and the P key is in the far upper right. But when you hold down this modifier key,
所以现在右边的每一个字母都与左边的某个字母相对应，并叠加在那个字母之上。然后要访问下一层，你必须按下修改键。例如，Q 键在最左上角，而 P 键在最右上角。但当你按住这个修改键时，
in this case the space bar, it changes the Q into a P. It's like when you hold down the shift key to get a capital letter. Right. And from there you can kind of generalize the rest of them. They're all mirrored in that same way And if this sounds like a little hard to follow and you're having trouble picturing it That's actually not really a problem because you're not meant to picture it and you're not meant to remember where these things are in spatial
在这个例子中是空格键，它就会把 Q 变成 P。就像你按住 Shift 键来输入大写字母一样。没错。从那里你可以把其余的按键推广开来。它们都以同样的方式镜像对应。如果这听起来有点难以理解，而且你很难想象出来，那其实真的没问题，因为你不需要去想象它，你也不需要在空间上记住这些东西在
Relationship to one another you're meant to remember them with your fingers And it's that mind-body connection that frankly shocked me with its efficacy. Like I could not believe how quickly my left hand learned to type things on the right side because I was using the same fingers and the same kinds of motions as I was used to using just as, you know, in a mirror image form.
彼此之间的相对关系。你要用你的手指来记住它们。正是这种身心连接，坦白说，其效率之高让我大吃一惊。我简直不敢相信我的左手学会用右侧打字的速度有多快，因为我使用的是跟以前完全相同的的手指和完全相同的动作，只不过是以镜像的形式。
Got it. Okay. So if you, you hit the Q with your pinky, the other pinky is for the P, which is all the way across the board. And you're basically keeping that consistent in favor of keeping it kind of like in the same relative position on the board. That is fascinating to me. Yeah, it is really fascinating and a bit magical and really awesome when it comes to the letter keys. But the problem is, because you have this tiny board, you have to cram all of these other functions in from other places too. Like the mirror only gets you at most, you know, two punctuation marks, generally just one letter, you know, from the right side. But these keys have as many as six different
明白了。好的。所以如果你用小指敲击 Q，另一个小指就对应 P，而 P 在整个键盘的最远端。你基本上保持了这一点的一致性，以换取将其保持在键盘上相对相同的位置。这对我来说太迷人了。是的，这真的很迷人，有点神奇，而且在字母键方面真的很棒。但问题是，因为你只有这个极小的键盘，你还得把其他地方的所有这些其他功能也硬塞进来。比如镜像最多只能给你提供两个标点符号，通常只有一个来自右侧的字母。但这些键有多达六种不同的
symbols. So for example, the Q key gets you to the P key really easily. But you also need it to get you to the right parentheses, the exclamation point, the hyphen, and it also serves on top of all of that as your delete key. So those parts became much harder to learn and the reality is you have to remember all of these different combinations and there's no safety net, there's no backup plan.
符号。例如，Q 键能让你非常容易地按到 P 键。但你还需要它来输入右括号、感叹号、连字符，而且最重要的是，它还充当你的删除键。所以那些部分变得更难学习，现实情况是你必须记住所有这些不同的组合，而且没有安全网，没有备用计划。
Like at least on a full keyboard, you can just hunt and peck around if you forget how to do some convoluted thing. But on this, you can't. You're just stuck and have to look it up. So you got all these keyboards from the library, and I'm sending a donation right away as soon as this is over. You should. And I'm sending a donation right away as soon as this is over But in the end, what did you choose for?
至少在全尺寸键盘上，如果你忘记了怎么做某项复杂的操作，你还可以用“一指禅”慢慢摸索。但在这种键盘上，你做不到。你只能卡住，然后不得不去查阅。所以你从图书馆借了所有的键盘，等这一切一结束我马上就捐款。你确实应该。等这一切一结束我马上就捐款，
Writing and facilitate your career as a writer Oh, so I went into this thinking like okay, I want an off-the-shelf solution, right? I want something that's one and done I'm gonna pick one of these three. It's just a matter of like which one. And suddenly I'm like, man, they really all have these advantages that I really like, but they also have these really serious downsides. Like the Maltron, you still have to move your hand around on a lot, and the Tippy has this completely new layout you need to learn, and the Half-Qwerty, it's probably my favorite of the bunch,
但最终，你为写作以及促进你的作家生涯选择了什么？哦，我一开始以为，好吧，我要一个开箱即用的解决方案，对吧？我想要一个一劳永逸的东西。我要在这三个里选一个。这只是个选哪一个的问题。突然之间，我觉得：天哪，它们确实都有我非常喜欢的优点，但它们也有非常严重的缺点。比如 Meltron，你仍然得在上面移动很多手；而 Tippy 则有全新的布局需要你去学习；至于半 QWERTY 键盘，它可能是我最喜欢的一个，
but you have to remember a ton of modifier key combinations to be able to use it, even at a basic level, because it has so few keys. So in the end, none of these was like my Goldilocks keyboard. But while I was researching the Half-QWERTY, what I learned is that some people have programmed their own two-handed keyboards to work the same way. So like you create a modifier on your keyboard and you press it down and it creates a mirror
但你必须记住大量的修改键组合才能使用它，即使在基础层面也是如此，因为它按键太少了。所以到头来，没有一个是我的“金发姑娘”键盘。但在研究半 QWERTY 键盘的过程中，我了解到有些人已经对他们自己的双手键盘进行了编程，使其以同样的方式工作。比如你在键盘上创建一个修改键，按下去它就会创建一个镜像
board. And what that means is that you can preserve all the functions on your normal keyboard that's right in front of you, but you can also access this other layer of everything that's on the right without having to move your hand to the right. And that was the key realization that just sort of opened the dam, because once I did that, right,
键盘。这意味着你可以保留就在你面前的普通键盘上的所有功能，但你也可以访问右侧所有东西的另一层，而无需将手移动到右侧。这是打破僵局的关键认识，因为一旦我做到了这一点，对吧，
once I learned that I could fairly easily program my keyboard to work like a mirror board and like a normal keyboard at the same time, I was like, well, what else can I get it to do? And so I created different layers with these different modifiers. You know, there's like a punctuation layer that's accessed with one button and like there's a layer for the numbers all kind of mirror as well as the letters. So you can still fall back on your normal layout if you're just hunting and pecking. But you also have this completely new way to learn how to use a keyboard one-handed. So basically you programmed all these layers of functions into the keyboard that you already
一旦我了解到我可以相当容易地将我的键盘编程为既像镜像键盘又像普通键盘时，我就在想：我还让它能做什么呢？于是我用这些不同的修改键创建了不同的层。你知道，有一个通过一个按钮就能访问的标点符号层，还有一个数字层，数字和字母一样也都是镜像的。所以如果你只是“一指禅”打字，你仍然可以退回到常规布局。但你也有了一种全新的、单手使用键盘的方法。所以基本上你在你已经拥有的键盘上编程了所有这些功能层，
have so you can use it as the mirrored one-handed keyboard if you want to, but you can also use it as a conventional keyboard if you forget or just don't feel like using the various key combinations because everything is still there on the right hand side. And that sounds like a brilliant solution. Yeah, I mean, I think of it as the best of all worlds, right? It's built into whatever device you have, right? And yeah, I retain all these functions that I had before and it is software-based,
这样你既可以根据需要将其用作镜像单手键盘，也可以在忘记时将其用作传统键盘，或者如果你不想使用各种按键组合，因为一切都还在右侧。听起来这真是一个绝妙的解决方案。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是集所有优点于一身的方案，对吧？它内置在你拥有的任何设备中，对吧？而且是的，我保留了以前拥有的所有这些功能，并且它是基于软件的，
which means you can copy and share it fairly easily. Like you could set this up at home in a couple of minutes. So I also have put it up on our website and like anybody who wants to download and use this thing, which I'm kind of tongue in cheek calling the Kirti, you know like Kirti. Like the files are there. I have like the sort of setup instructions,
这意味着你可以相当容易地复制和分享它。你可以在几分钟内在家里设置好这个。所以我把它放到了我们的网站上，任何想要下载和使用这个东西的人——我半开玩笑地把它叫做 Kirti（柯蒂），就像 Kirti 一样。文件都在那里。我写好了设置说明。
like a guide for labeling your keys with these different kind of layers of functionality, all that's on the website and it's free. And in addition to that, this is a whole series that you created called Adapt or Design. That's a web series of many articles on the website. Can you describe a little bit more
就像一个教你如何用不同功能层级来给按键做标记的指南，这些都在网站上，而且是免费的。除此之外，你还创作了一个名为“适应或设计”的系列节目。那是网站上包含许多文章的网络系列。你能再稍微介绍一下
about what people will find there? Yeah, yeah. Well, it's like a play on sort of a adapt or die. And, but the idea is like, you know, I had to adapt or design my way out of all these problems And so I wanted to share those challenges and solutions with people. So it's a series of articles that are about Things like, you know how to adapt to one-handedness including like, you know challenges I faced and solutions I found that I'd really like to help other people leapfrog if they encounter similar situations.
大家在那里能找到什么吗？好啊。嗯，这有点像是对“适应或死亡”的一种文字游戏。但核心想法是，你知道的，我必须通过适应或设计来摆脱所有这些问题，所以我想把这些挑战和解决方法分享给大家。因此，这个系列的文章涵盖了
And then also things about long haul recoveries after a severe nerve injury and all that that entails and how to organize your rehabilitation and how design can play a role in that too. Wow. And so lastly, how are you feeling right now? Where are we one year later? Yeah, well, I'm a lot better in a lot of ways.
比如如何适应单手状态，包括我面临的挑战以及找到的解决方案，如果其他人遇到类似情况，我真的希望能帮他们少走弯路。还有关于严重神经损伤后的长期康复，其中涉及的种种以及如何组织康复训练，还有设计在其中能发挥怎样的作用。哇。那么最后，你现在感觉怎么样？我们来到一年后了？是的，嗯，很多方面我都好多了。
I've regained some functionality in my arm and my hand. I'd like to say that I'm at like the kind of claw game phase of my recovery where like I can kind of like hover my hand over things and like drop it down like one of those arcade chains where you gotta try to grab that prize and then like lift it back out. And sometimes it works, but often it doesn't. And so- It really often doesn't.
我的手臂和手恢复了一些功能。我想说，我目前处于康复过程中的“抓娃娃机”阶段，就像我可以把手悬在物品上方，然后像那种街机抓娃娃一样把它放下去，试图抓到那个奖品，然后再把它提起来。有时能成功，但往往抓不到。而且——真的是经常抓不到。
My kid spent an inordinate amount of money in Japan on those machines, okay. Yeah, so I used that as kind of like the inspiration for the logo for this series. And then, but yeah, like overall, you know, I feel a lot better. Like the pain, which was at one point excruciating and borderline intolerable is much reduced.
我的孩子在日本的那些机器上花了大笔的钱呢。是的，所以我把这个当作这个系列标志的灵感来源。不过，总体来说，你知道的，我感觉好多了。曾经一度折磨人且几乎难以忍受的疼痛已经大大减轻了。
And yeah, I'm starting to be able to incorporate my right arm and hand again into functional things, but I am still, you know, when I go for my keys and I open the front door, my left hand is still not smart enough to get the key in the right spot consistently. And it's kind of remarkable to me. Like, you know, I feel like if I was a kid, I probably would have adapted by now.
是的，我的右臂和右手开始能够重新参与到一些实用的功能性动作中了，但我还是——你知道的，当我去找钥匙开前门时，我的左手还是不够灵巧，无法每次都准确地把钥匙插进孔里。这对我来说挺神奇的。就像，你知道的，我觉得如果我是个孩子，我大概现在已经适应了。
But you know, as an old, my right hand dominance sort of remains. And so I'm hoping that eventually that hand can once again be the dominant hand rather than the sort of dumb cousin of my left Well, I really appreciate you taking the time Kurt and for sharing all this with everybody. It really is a great service So thank you so much. Yeah Roman. Thanks for having me You can find all of Kurt's adapt or design articles as well as instructions on how to set up your own KERDI keyboard at 99pi.org slash adapt. 99% Invisible was produced this week by our digital director Kurt Kohlstedt and Isabel Angel and edited by Kelly Prime mixed by Martine Gonzalez music by Swan Real.
但你知道，作为成年人，我的右利手习惯似乎依然存在。所以我希望这只手最终能重新成为主导手，而不是变成我左手的那个笨拙表亲。嗯，非常感谢你抽出时间，科特，也感谢你与大家分享这一切。这真的是一份极好的贡献，非常感谢你。好的，罗曼。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在 99pi.org/adapt 上找到科特的所有“适应或设计”文章，以及如何设置你自己的 KERDI 键盘的说明。本周的《99%无形》由我们的数字总监科特·科尔斯泰特和伊莎贝尔·安杰尔制作，凯利·普赖姆剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。
Cathy too is our executive producer Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashma Don, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on blue sky as well as our own discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99 PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
凯茜·涂是我们的执行制作人，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、拉什马·唐、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·麦地那·格利森，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们现在是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，总部设在美丽加州奥克兰市中心上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在蓝天（BlueSky）以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。99PI 网站 99PI.org 上有通往该服务器的链接以及历期节目的链接。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。